Chris waters here with the GameSpot news
update Microsoft has announced the four
free games you're gonna get in July if
you're an Xbox Live Gold member which
include one that you could actually get
in June this is only the second month
that games with gold has included Xbox
one games and unlike with Sony's
PlayStation Plus instant collection
it appears that Microsoft will not be
completely swapping out the games every
month max the curse of the Brotherhood
has been free for all of June and will
continue to be available throughout July
halo Spartan assault on the other hand
will be replaced with the excellent
guacamelee Super Turbo Championship
Edition that game is great on the Xbox
360 side of things Gotham City Impostors
will be free starting July 1st and on
July 16th it will be swapped out with
battleblock theater for the rest of the
month as with PlayStation Plus Xbox Live
users will have access to the games for
as long as they remain gold subscribers
and as long as they grab them during the
free period it is possible to redownload
them later if you want to learn more
about max the curse of Brotherhood
Gotham City Impostors battleblock
theater or guacamelee you can check out
the reviews on GameSpot calm most of
them are pretty good enjoy
you